un autre jeune qui lui aussi va tenir là
fils encore un long moment pas dans le
domaine du cinéma mais dans celui de la
musique c'est daniel barenboim un peu
plus de 30 ans il est devenu en quelques
années l'une des stars de la direction
d'orchestre il est à paris demain il
présentera les projets qu'il peut avoir
avec leur caisse de paris qu'il dirige
mais tout de suite découvrons barenboim
qui est il ce jeune homme à limbé verini
l'a suivi
je
de plus
oh
excusez je pleure pas par émotion mais
j'aime beaucoup mangé le cuisinent
indien j'aime manger régulièrement et je
déteste de vie où il n'ya pas de mode ou
de vos restaurants guen ou rouge et pas
d'amis que
kim ça ou je peux manger chez eux ou
pour faire l'acquisition
mais de l'aveu de la aimé la cuisine et
puis là la pratique il ya un
mois
mais vous savez merci papa professionnel
vous
écouter vous écouter vous allez voir
mais moi je vous préparez vos frais
d'hôpital
je vous prépare à
ce que vous savez c'est un peu la même
chose vous avez un orchestre vous essayé
de mélanger toutes les sonorités ici on
va essayer de ménager les oignons avec
des tomates et avec de l'ail à
le résultat total du groupe à la fin et
vous savez pour moi c'est très violent
cuisine comme ça parce qu'on ne sait
jamais avec la situation financière
montre mots les médecins ont dit qu'on
va pas avoir toujours d'orchestre monde
ils vont pas le passé d'argent pour
subventionner les eaux cristallines vaut
mieux rentrer un deuxième métier de
façon pour ces chefs voilà
toute
cette musique entre l'interprète
de faire un acte de récréation est
toujours content contemplative parce que
les coupes c'est le compositeur qui a
déjà eu toute la partie si vous voulez
active de l'inspiration et l'a mis dans
le papier est ce qui vous fait ce qu'on
fait comme interprète dans le plu au
sens du mot et contemplative et pour ça
il faut avoir une
paix intérieure si vous voulez que même
dans le moment le plus excitant de la
musique même de tristan santiago ski ou
tout le monde joue et ça fera 2 vite
fort et beaucoup de l'excitation martin
au bout du coin c'est quand même
sympathique
il faut parfois que pour aller à un
concert il faut savoir que le deuxième
thème est écrit d'une façon comme ça s
est plus lent c'est moi ça reste une
tonalité tel laissé sasha bien sûr
surtout savoir tout ça ça peut pas
déranger je vous le savez pour écouter
la musique on perd on peut c'est mignon
oui vraiment on doit même nom on devrait
même battre
ça vous vous regrettez pas de ne pas
être ignorant ce qui concerne le jeu
vous savez sa voix à non vous savez
c'est un cliché mais vraiment le vieux
clichés plus on sait au moins on reste
dans la musique c'est très roots youtube
surtout pour un siège au caire dans la
direction nos questions on peut jamais
arriver à une maîtrise si vous voulez de
la matière parce que la matière ce sont
des êtres humains c'est pas bien aux
environs on peut jamais arriver une
maîtrise totale
de la matière est ce pour ça qu'on peut
on a toujours l'impression de deux des
plus en plus et ignorante je sais que
c'est pas une fausse modestie ce qui
vous dit maintenant mais c'est un
sentiment très vrai et pour que le
connaissant ses grandes puissances et on
s'écarte finalement oui parce qu'il est
conscient des limites
de la connaissance
c'était pas le droit de parler des
choses comme ça ici
oui oui
oui
il ya des musiciens que vous allez vous
aller les écouter et il vous donne
l'impression que ce qu'ils font est si
difficile si abominablement difficile
qui vous pouvais jamais y arriver c'est
bien sur 16 ça vous fait une impression
très fort il ya d autres qui vous donne
l'impression de ce qu'ils font est si
facile qui vous pouvez le faire vous
même je me rappelle la première fois que
je suis allé en attente de rubinstein un
jeu d enfant et ça avait l'air je
souligne l'air pas ce qui se passe sa
valeur de facilité incroyable et j'avais
je voulais vraiment demandé mais si
c'est comme ça tout le monde peut jouer
et
quand je vais à penser à moi je m'en
fous si le chef dirige à parker ou avec
la partition ou avec facilité ou bruce
en facilité s'il me touche
c'est tout bon -
dont commence et tout le reste comme
beaucoup moi oui non l'émotion prime a
fait l'émotion la totalité l'expérience
musicale contenu émotionnel
intellectuelle technique tout pas du
tout ménagé les unités
où
m
et
alors la d re sonore est par définition
doit vous donner
certains conscience et l'objectivité par
contre
le vous voulez la sensation physique de
leur production du son vous pouvez la
voir ta joie vous avez un plan et vous
fait sortir la sonorité c'est pas la
même chose si vous avez avec vous une
grande claque un clarinettiste qui vous
fait le phrasé avec vous n'est ce pas
c'est pas la même chose de vrais
sentiments de sensations physiques le
produit rance un son et c'est pour ça
que je voudrais jamais
faire la salle d'eau et pour moi les
deux activités sont complètement
complémentaires
si je comprends bien vous préférez
combine interprétez-vous même heure non
pas du tout non pas du tout il y est la
sensation de la castration physique
ouais mais c'est physique c'est pas tout
mais sensuelle que que cérébral à
nous jeter il faut savoir quand est
cérébral et france assure c'est tout
mg je vais voir les grands joueurs
pour bout et sociales ou sensuelle
une question qu'on se pose est quand
même normal moi aussi à bord
moi je pensais que vous pouviez voir un
élément